welcome to sas talks money on
valuetainment i'm your host adam sasik
and i'm here
to help you build your wealth and save
that money on today's episode we're
gonna be breaking down stock
market terminology for dummies
let's talk
so question for you how often do you
turn on the tv and you watch cnbc or
bloomberg or read a newspaper a wall
street journal
and you wonder what the hell are these
people even talking about well i got to
tell you something
that happens to me all the time and i'm
in the money game so if you're not in
the money game and you're not an
investment strategist financial advisor
you might hear some of these terms and
be like
dude i got no clue what this guy just
said so today
we're going to break down money in a
language that you
can understand and we're going to break
down stock market terminology
that you should know so with that being
said we got a list
behind me it's a through z we're going
to go down the line of the alphabet
of certain words that you should know
and of course we're going to start
with a so a acid allocation this might
be the most important terminology
for you to know acid allocation aka your
asset mix this is basically the balance
between your stocks and bonds they say
depending on your age
that's how much you should have in
stocks or bonds so as an example
if you're 25 years old you should maybe
have 75 percent
in stocks 25 bonds if you're 75 years
old
you should have maybe 75 percent in
bonds and 25
stocks make sense asset allocation the
younger you are the more risk you can
take
that stocks the older you are the less
risk that you should take
that's bonds moving right along let's go
to b bonds
bonds are an iou to a company
or government that's when you lend a
company or government
money that's a bond pretty simple that's
a bond next you got bull
or bear market you always hear the bull
it's a bear market is a bull market
there's a bull market bear market
it's pretty simple a bull market is when
the market is
going up and a bear market is when the
market is going down so that's bull
versus bear there you go next thing you
know you got capital
gain capital gain is a profit from a
stock
sale and it's usually over one year so
sometimes you get taxed
at ordinary income that's income that
you make
in a year or a year or less capital gain
is a year
or longer next we got compound interest
this might be my favorite thing with
investing this is your money
making money and your interest making
interest and your money make an interest
in your interest making money albert
einstein once said compound interest is
the eighth
wonder of the world he who understands
it
earns it he who does not pays it pretty
profound stuff right there
from albert einstein that's compound
interest next you got diversification
this is where you spread risk
among different asset classes you know
how they say don't put all your eggs in
one basket well that's
diversification there we go the next
thing we got is dividend
dividend is what a company's earnings
are paid
to shareholders that's collecting
dividends
next up dow jones these are the 30
largest
blue chip stocks on the stock market so
you know when they say
the market did this today and the market
went up today or the market went down
today they're usually talking about
what the dow jones did the stock market
that's the dow
then you got equities equities are just
ownership in a company this is equities
aka
stock so some people say what's equities
it's just stock it's shares
shares stock equities these words are
all pretty interchangeable
last up on this side of the list we got
etf this stands for exchange
traded funds exchange traded funds are a
collection of stocks
that track and index over time these
typically return a 12
rate of return on the high side not a
bad thing to invest in
etfs moving right along at the top of
this list you got fiduciary a fiduciary
acts with your
best interests in mind make sure that
you're working with someone who is a
fiduciary
and not of a douche bag see what i did
there
there we go fiduciary fixed income fixed
income
is a security that pays a specific
interest rate this is typically
known as bonds fixed income typically
known as bonds
can also be preferred stock next up we
got growth stock
growth stock is a strategy to invest in
rapid
growing stocks that's growth stock then
we got hedge fund this is usually
something that the ultra ultra ultra
wealthy
invest in a hedge fund is a strategy
used by wealthy investors
to pool funds to beat the market that's
a hedge fund then you got index
index are just indicators of the market
like we talked about the dow jones
at the top 30 blue chip companies
america that's an index but the best
known index
is the s p 500 which is an index of the
top
500 largest companies in america so this
index is just an
indicator of the market you always hear
i'm index investing
i'm index investing that's just
mirroring the market
by indexing the market then you've got
ipo this stands for
initial public offering this is when a
private
company is about to go public they do an
i
p o that's ipo then you got ira this
stands for
individual retirement account these are
typically
tax favored accounts tax advantage
individual retirement account
ira then you got junk bonds these are
low rated
high return highly risky bonds
junk bonds so someone says yeah i'm a
junk bond investor it's like
good luck with that buddy good luck cool
that's a junk bond
then you got kpi kpi
stands for key performance indicator or
a company's
long term growth trajectory
kpi key performance indicator
say that three times fast then you got
long-term investing this is i'm a huge
advocate
of long-term investing this is just a
buy and hold
strategy when someone says like what's
your strategy what's your what's your
what's your secret to investing it's
like
i'm just in the market and i don't sell
and i keep my money in the market and
over time
the market will go up long-term
investing buy
and hold investing there's no secret
sauce with that
and it works that's long-term investing
then you got mutual fund a mutual fund
is money pooled from people invested in
multiple stocks
in bonds or both so i highly recommend
that people when they start investing
they do not
select certain stocks you might get
lucky you might not
if you invest in a large pool of funds
or a mutual fund
you'll be playing the entire market this
is diversification
and asset allocation all in one in a
mutual fund
sometimes this will be called an index
fund or index mutual fund
if you use an index strategy of using an
indicator of the market like an s p
500 that's a mutual fund index fund
these terms are
kind of interchangeable the key
terminology here is sometimes mutual
funds
are more expensive index funds are less
expensive
so there you go save that money moving
right along you got the nasdaq the
nasdaq is a computerized
stock exchange and this is very very
heavily
tech centric so you got apple you got
google you got microsoft
you got types of companies like this
that are all on the nasdaq these are
tech companies
moving right along you got the nyse the
new york stock exchanges is the largest
stock exchange in the world read up if
you don't know about the new york stock
exchange
then you got option an option is a
contractual agreement
between two parties to a buy or sell
or a call or a put so i know people that
specialize
in options they're options traders this
is very difficult
and i don't recommend it for the
individual investor stick to mutual
funds and index funds
not necessarily options but now the more
you know
options there you go then you got
portfolio this is basically like
when someone says how's your portfolio
look and this is just like what you got
this is your collection
of stocks this is your collection of
assets what's your portfolio looking
like
is it opposite down it's just what you
own that's your portfolio
then you got prospectus a prospectus is
actually very important very
few people read a company's prospectus
but i highly recommend it if you're
going to be investing it might be boring
it might be long
but this is the definition it's a
document of a company's
financial history that's the prospectus
warren buffett usually recommends
always reading the company's prospectus
before you invest then you've got
quarterly earnings quarterly earnings or
just what it shows
a company's earnings every quarter how
many quarters in a year
well four how many quarters are in a
game well four so there you go companies
earnings
by quarter that's quarterly earnings
then you got reits i'm a huge advocate
of
reits order reits with a real estate
investment
trust real estate investment trust so
this enables you to invest in real
estate
without actually having to have a
mortgage and owning your home so i'm a
huge advocate of renting
but i invest in real estate or reits
then you got risk and return this is
basically the whole thing with investing
the higher the risk the higher the
return the lower the risk
the lower the return like we talked
about stocks and bonds in your asset
allocation
the more bonds you have they're more
like a stabilizing force in your
portfolio
typically the lower the return the more
stocks you have in your portfolio
typically the higher return so that's
risk and reward just like in anything
with life
the more you risk the higher the reward
the less you risk the less the reward
it's funny how that works sometimes then
you got the s p 500 which we've
discussed it stands for the standard
and poor's 500 a lot of people know
about the s p 500 but they don't know
that it stands for the standard
and poor's 500 that's the 500 largest
companies in america
that are on the s p 500 the s p 500
is an index or an indicator of the
overall stock market
check that out moving right along you
got stock this is share
this is equity this is owning a piece of
a company we cover that in equities
stock you got stock in a company the
stock is growing
that's stock here we go you got stock
you got bought then you get the ticker
symbol this is basically just the stock
symbol so when you say all right like
how's apple doing today well you don't
just look under apple
you don't just look at a picture of an
apple apple's ticker symbol is aapl
okay so that's apple that's their ticker
symbol
then you've got time horizon this is
basically the time
one plans to hold an investment like
what's your time horizon like for me
my time horizon i'm just holding i'm a
buy and hold an investor i might cash
out in my 50s and my 60s and my 70s
who knows but i'm investing since i've
been 27 years old
right i'm investing for almost 13 years
now my buy and hold strategy
is a long term strategy that's the time
horizon so there you go then you got
uptick uptick is an increase
in price from the last transaction so i
got in at 50
and now i'm at 60. it's uptick 10 points
so cool i'm up 10. that's the uptick
volatility this is like oh crazy how
crazy is the market
how crazy is the market today how much
action is going on in the market this is
actually calculated by something known
as the vix
vix the vix this is volatility in the
market this is the expected
price fluctuation in the market that's
the vix that's volatility and then we
got
the weighted average market cap this is
just a fancy fancy complicated word
for basically the larger the company the
higher the score
on the weighted average market cap i
needed to use a w
and i threw that one in there that's not
a term that you might hear all that
often that's a w
and also the same thing i needed to find
an x i was like what the hell is going
on with x
i found something called x rt to be
honest i've never even used this term
before
this is me being honest with you but xrt
is basically what's called
your x rights this is basically when a
buyer can't buy more stock
at a cheaper price that's not a term
you'll hear often
but we had to find the next so we found
the x there it is for you
then you got yield this is the annual
percentage
rate of return on your capital like what
did the bond yield
well the bond yielded a 3.6 percent that
was the yield
what did the stock yield the stock
yielded 9.7 percent cool that's the
yield and
last but not least we got z which stands
for zero why did i pick the word zero
well i'll tell you why only
55 percent of americans are invested
in the stock market so what does that
mean forty five percent of people
watching this
are simply just not invested in the
stock market well you know how much
money you can make
from the stock market if you're not
invested well the answer
is zero so i would highly encourage you
to look
more into the stock market i hope that
this stock market terminology
helped and broke down money in a
language that you can understand
i want to see you win with money and it
starts with
understanding the basics of the stock
market
with that being said i hope you enjoyed
this episode if you have not seen my
episode
on investing in the stock market then
versus now
check that out right here and if you
have not subscribed to valuetainment
economics
please subscribe below and smash that
like button while you're at it
and last but not least you can't invest
in the stock market unless
you save that money all we talk is is